This video is brought to you by blinkers now.
Like it's not always easy to find the time to sit down and read all the books
you want to look. I'm a pretty busy dude myself.
So I understand that I don't read as much as I would.
Like I don't read as much as I used to. It's all a bit of a shame,
but good news. I've got Blinkist, which is this app that you can download.
And in this app,
there are 15 minutes summaries of all the best non-fiction books.
Over 3000 of them entire soul. You can either read them or listen to them,
both options there for me, I listen 90% of the time.
Like it's easy to fit into the day like that commute to work, or, uh, you know,
just doing little tasks around the house. It's pretty perfect.
I'll say 12 million active users currently use Blinkist and they're getting the
best insights and needs no info from thousands of books. Self-help to business,
to health, whatever you're into it's on there.
They also have excellent curated lists where the Blinkist team and also guests
to put together some specific recommendations. Like what have we got here?
How to future-proof yourself? Well, that's a good one.
And also a staff favorites. Of course you want to know what they think.
And of course you can download all of these, listened to them,
read them offline. It's all pretty fantastic.
I've read a bunch of stuff on here. They're 15 minutes.
They easy to whip through, and it's just very dense information.
The first hundred people to go to blinkist.com forward slash visual politic.
We'll get one week to try it out.
You'll also get 25% off if you want the full membership and let's get into it.
If we mentioned espionage, it'll likely trigger a movie scene,
starring Sean Connery, Roger Moore, or Pierce Brosnan. I mean,
who doesn't remember agent [inaudible] classic Aston Martin.
However.
Fortunately,
or unfortunately the truth is that real world espionage has little to do with
the crazy and glamorous life of James bonds. It makes sense. I mean,
who in their right mind would go to see a movie in which Prius Brosnan spent 120
minutes listening to phone calls or collecting metadata.
That's what it boils down to from ancient Rome to the present day.
This has basically been the mission of intelligence services to know what is
being said and who is saying it.
Yes,
Julius Caesar may not have had powerful computer equipment or satellites at his
disposal, but he was sped several times from death.
Thanks to having a powerful network of informants at his service. In fact,
it's even been said that he might've been aware of the conspiracy that finally
ended his life. For another example,
the French revolution started by Robert P Erin's company.
Most likely would not have been possible without an intelligence network,
either. Not at least in the way that it occurred.
The revolutionary governments had intelligence committees spread across the
country that would dedicate to do identifying, monitoring,
and arresting any noble foreign or Frenchmen who returned from abroad.
And it would be against the movement to give you an idea.
Some historians estimate the number of people monitored by this huge network is
almost.
Half a million.
Plus, we're going to jump from the 18th century to 2013.
Was that here and leak from a technology consultant say until then,
unknown Edward Snowden shook all the seats.
We are in Washington.
Journalists from the Washington post and the guardian,
the national security agency, employee links,
documents classified as top secret revealing the existence of several
intelligence programs, programs that collected metadata from us, citizens.
In bulk. But what exactly? Yeah.
Where are these programs? What is the NSA really?
And what role did nine 11 play in terms of privacy? Well, watch closely,
because in this video, we're going to answer all of these questions.
The secret agency
on the 20th of May.
1949, then you are secretary of defense Louis.
A Johnson created the AFSA, the armed forces security agency,
its purpose was to coordinate all electronic communications and intelligence
findings of the different agencies, belonging to the armed forces agencies,
such as the air force security service, all the Marines.
However, the AFSA was a resounding failure.
The rivalry between the different agencies were so great in the ends.
They've never shared all the information with a central organization.
It.
Is precisely for this reason and because the AFSA has ended up being totally
inoperative and is unable to respond to the needs posed by the new cold war.
The president Truman decided in June,
1952 to make us stand and Mount something completely new.
And this way he authorized the creation of a new secret agency.
He did it through a confidential memo,
specifically at the ends of the seventh page of the documents.
They were brief lines that would change the history of espionage and Norway.
That's America forever.
Can you imagine.
Dictating the document to a secretary off to six pages? All of a sudden, Oh,
Hey, yes.
Look also put in the point where we're going to create that mega agency,
but you know, don't let anyone know, especially in our Congress, please,
That's how the NSA was born. Very sneakily. However,
it would not be until more than 20 years later,
that it was publicly known that this agency even existed. In fact,
it was learned about by investigations carried out in 1975 by the Senate,
since the possible abuses of us intelligence services.
Was.
And that the church committee revealed that there was an agency with a
multi-million dollar budgets and agency that no one had ever heard of.
Even the sentences themselves did not give credence to the scale that the NSA
had reached.
Unlike the CIA, which was created through Congress,
the NSA had been launched directly Boeing,
the executive branch that is by the United States government itself for decades,
the white house carried out painstaking work,
let it go completely unnoticed while the organization kept growing and growing.
But in Congress, they couldn't believe it.
They had just discovered that the NSA,
a virtually unknown organization was not only a larger agency than the CIA
itself, but was in fact larger than all the other intelligence agencies,
correct.
[Inaudible].
To get an idea of its size. The last known fact is that in 1978,
and despite the concept brought by the end of the Vietnam war,
the NSA workforce amounted to 68,203 employees,
this is more than half of Apple's employees worldwide.
And remember all of this was done in absolute secrecy.
Despite its size and power,
no law has ever been enacted prohibiting the NSA from engaging in any activity.
There are only laws to prohibit the release of any information about the agency.
No statute establishes the NSC or defines the permissible scope of its
responsibilities, Frank Church, former Senate intelligence committee.
And if this already seems surprising, well,
hold on because the story doesn't end here.
Yeah.
The Senate also discovered that the NSA had dedicated itself to tapping the
phones of nearly 1,700 us citizens. Even back in 1969,
the Nixon administration came to name this particular list of people to watch.
It would be known as operation minarets. It was a scandal,
such prominent characters as Martin Luther King,
Jane Fonda and Muhammad Ali were parts of this curious NSA blacklist.
Oh.
In fact,
the paranoia of the Nixon administration was such that they even engaged in
spying on their own people. For example,
well-known Tennessee Republican Senator Howard Baker,
who became majority leader in the Senate and was later president Ronald
Reagan's. Chief of staff was also on the NSA's list of suspects
1978.
And probably as a result of discovering the opaque and controversial workings of
the NSA Congress approves the so-called FISA,
the foreign intelligence surveillance act FISA legally put brakes on the NSA's
freedom to listen to who they wanted from that point on,
since the passing of that, nor the NSA could only intercepts,
he listened to communications that took place abroad,
expressly prohibiting surveillance of us citizens,
except in the case of those acting as spies from other countries.
Sorry.
Just to gain faeces approval to initiate citizen monitoring,
the NSA needed to obtain a court order, which, you know, all seems pretty right.
Well.
Hang on a moment because there was an event that would completely change the
boundaries of this agency.
Good evening today, our fellow citizens,
our way of life,
our very freedom came under attack in a series of deliberate and deadly
terrorist.
The day that changed everything.
There is a date on the calendar that was market turning point for the U S
national security agency, September the 11th, 2001. Yeah.
Yeah.
Decades off to that fateful day.
We could almost certainly say that nine 11 has been the most consequential
terrorist operation in human history. On that day, 19 jihadists,
3000 innocent lives and iconic building the twin towers of the world trade
center, and four passenger planes disappeared from the face of the earth.
But not only that, there was a lot that was not destroyed,
but was damaged in some cases forever. Thousands of wounded,
the strategic Pentagon building and to country, that would never be the same.
Yeah.
No 11 disrupted the political agenda of the Bush administration.
And we're not just talking about the Wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
Practically gave then president Bush,
a blank check to use the armed forces in any way.
He deemed necessary to persecute and punish anyone who had been involved in the
attacks and that wasn't all a month after nine 11 Congress passed the Patriot
act law that empowered them to fight terrorism with the same tactics that they
could employ to find organized crime or drug trafficking. For example,
thanks to the Patriot acts.
Agents could gain access to a terrorist suspected call history, travel plans,
or any other information available from other federal agencies.
Today, we take an essential step in defeating terrorism while protecting the
constitutional rights of all Americans. With my signature,
this law will give intelligence and law enforcement officials important new
tools to fight a present danger.
But it didn't end that.
It's definitely been a slap in the face for someone.
It was a slap in the face for the intelligence agents.
It was clear more intelligence was needed in 2002 president Bush signed a
presidential secret order,
an order allowing the NSA to monitor calls and emails from thousands of us,
citizens and legal residents without having to seek a court order.
It was the birth of the stellar Winnsboro.
The icing on the cake came in 2005 with the appointments of a new director for
the NSA,
the man who signified a new era in the history of the NSA and by extension,
the history of espionage.
Gosh.
A cowboy in Washington.
On August,
the first 2005 general Keith Alexander was appointed as the 16th director of the
NSA serving in office for a total of nine years.
No director of the agency has ever served that long. And of course,
no director has had so much power in his hands before this character,
his ambition was simply unprecedented.
Alexander tended to be a bit of a cowboy. Let's not worry about the law.
Let's just figure out how to get the job done says a former intelligence
official. He said at one point, a lot of things clearly legal,
but that doesn't make them illegal.
A former military intelligence officer who served under Alexander at
[inaudible].
Apparently Alexander seems like the perfect guy for the job.
He was a senior decorated intelligence officer, a graduate of West point.
He specialized in physics and technology. For example, during the Iraq war,
he pioneered tools to monitor all communications calls, emails,
messages coming out of Iraq in real time.
However, his predecessor,
former NSA director general Michael Hayden could not stand the sight of
Alexander. Of course Alexander had not one,
but two ACEs up his sleeve to take the top seat. First,
he knew Hayden hated then defense secretary, Donald Rumsfeld.
So he made Rumsfeld his first target.
[Inaudible].
He knew how to move around Washington like a fish in water. Well,
let's just say he knew how to charm the people that you need to do in order to
achieve all of his goals.
Now four-star general was running an intelligence command in Virginia,
near Washington, to give you an idea of the kind of person we're talking about.
He set up a Hollywood like set in those facilities,
specifically a replica of the star Trek enterprises command.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. You might be wondering why on earth did he do that?
Well from this command post, you control the screens and computers.
If it's so-called information, domain center and not just that in this way,
every time he invited a politician to tour the facility,
he ended up seating his guest and the seat belonging to the captain of the
enterprise. And you know what? Politicians freaked out. They gave him.
Loved.
It's hard to believe,
but with techniques like this general Xander somehow managed to get everyone on
his side. And yes, that's also how he became the director of the powerful NSA.
[Inaudible].
But let's not get distracted. The fact is the during Alexander's long tenure,
one of his main objectives was to renew the agency, technologically,
perhaps one of the characters that best illustrates the changes that occurred in
this organization is Edward Snowden.
And with Alexandra at the helm,
the agency was filled with fresh young personnel.
Overnight 20 somethings were walking around the NSA facilities with levels of
access that even the most senior agents had never gained,
but digital age had arrived.
I was decades younger than the help desk folks and heading past them into a volt
to which they didn't have access and never would Edward Snowden.
With its new payroll signings, Alexandra revamped,
the NSA and began carrying out new espionage program.
Yes.
It was controversial was the prison program with it's.
The NSA began storing information from the internet and technology companies,
emails, video chat, social media messages.
Everything was within reach of agency analysts to look for clues about.
New terrorist threats. In fact.
Information was stored by this agency that the NSA ran out of storage capacity
on its 141 hectors at Fort Meade that do expands their hard drive by setting up
a facility in the middle of the Utah desert that cost them more than $2 billion.
But do you know.
How many people are estimated to have been monitored by the NSA with this
program? How many terrorist suspects? Well,
it's estimated that the amounts could run to tens of millions of Americans. Yep.
That's right. Tens of millions.
How did the NSA legally justify monitoring so many people?
Well, as the saying goes well, there's a law, there's a loophole. Chris English,
the deputy director of the agency stated in Congress that when a potential
terrorist was under surveillance communications from people related to them were
investigators up to a certain degree of connection.
And of course,
if we take into account that a recent study conducted by the university of Milan
in conjunction with Facebook, estimated that at present,
we are all connected with about 4.7 degrees of separation.
And the three degrees used by the NSA does look a bit, let's say excessive.
It was a bit of a joke because in practice they just had free reign to
investigate whoever they wanted.
Xander.
He had all these diagrams showing how this guy was connected to that guy and to
that guy.
So says a former NSA official who haired Alexander give briefings on the floor
of the information dominance center.
Some of my colleagues and I were skeptical laser,
we had a chance to review the information.
It turns out that all that those guys were connected to where pizza shops are
retired. Military officer who worked with Alexander, all this.
I got very much out of hands for the NSA document.
Leaks revealed to them more than 10 million phone calls were intercepted in
Spain and France alone. In fact,
many of you may remember this embarrassing moment during the Obama
administration, Obama.
Approved tapping Angela Merkel's phone three years ago,
president Barack Obama was told about monitoring of German chancellor in 2010
and allowed it to continue Telegraph.
Emails of the then president of Mexico for Lebeck outer on and 35.
Other heads of
Extend to the program was such that Snowden himself began to recognize that
there were NSA employees who were spying on their ex partners or whoever they
wanted with absolute impunity.
So the agency itself,
the benefits have been quite small compared to the cost and resources used.
It seems that using such a large amount of data in practice was not easy.
Say that at the moment of reckoning,
the program was used bore to spy on the girlfriends of agency employees and
things like that than it was used to fight terrorism as well.
Also spying on political leaders like Merkel,
but how can we be sure that this no longer continues in any case?
The agreed goal was not to violate the privacy of millions of people around the
world and to spend billions of dollars in the process.
Anyway.
That is the story of one of the most covert intelligence agencies in the world.
An agency that for more than 20 years was de facto his,
and even to the United States,
Congress and agency whose daily activities we have no idea about.
But we do know that it was able to unscrupulously violate the,
of millions of innocent citizens among them businessmen, politicians,
and journalists. And that should cause us to ask ourselves a few questions.
Do you think it is appropriate for a government dependent body to have such a
degree of freedom?
Would you be willing to sacrifice all your privacy to supposedly strengthen
national security?
What control do you think that these kinds of agencies should have while leave
us your answers in the comments below also sooner at visual politic?
We're going to tell you more details about this world.
So don't forget to subscribe. And of course, if you found this interesting,
please do hit that thumbs up button.
Don't forget to subscribe and I'll see you next time.
[Inaudible].